[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt haben sei
nicht auszuschließen
heute gibt es eine motiv torte wir haben
einen besonderen anlass der hansestadt
geburtstag wird sie sagen die rechte
bekommt ist okay 720 und und deswegen
gibt es eine batman motiv heute in hamm
sanitär batman über alles die torte die
war gar nicht so zeitaufwendig die hat
einen tab tage gedauert aber wenn wir
auch gefilmt deswegen braucht ihr nicht
so lange also es geht ein gericht
schnell dafür dass ohne motiv torte ist
gefüllt ist die torte mit einem saftigen
schoko boden mit einer tat beta gamma
und um so ein bisschen feuchtigkeit mit
reinzubringen haben wir noch tiefkühl
himbeeren und eine leckere marmelade und
ich möchte ihnen auch noch bedanken bei
haben so dass wir uns dieses bild im
hintergrund geliehen hat und extra von
seinem zimmer hierher transportiert hat
und dann auch noch so richtig viele
klagen gearbeitet hat schaut euch mal
die filigrane arbeit an
okay da nichts an der wand naja bleibt
ob er bis zum schluss dran wenn der
wendehammer probierten euch seine
ehrliche meinung über diese torte sagt
für die herstellung der batman torte
starten wir zuallererst mit der cash
hierfür benötigen wir zeigt peter
kuvertüre und sahne
die sahne gebe ich in meinen kochtopf
und lasse sie einmal aufkochen
sobald die sonne dann gerade so hoch
steigen will nehmen wie sie vom herd und
gießen sie über unsere klein gehackte
zeit bitter kuvertüre
[Musik]
nun wird das einmal bedeckt und fünf
minuten stehen gelassen damit die
kuvertüre auch in der heißen sonne
schmelzen kann nach den fünf minuten
wird das mit dem teig schön verrührt so
dass sich alles miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
das muss jetzt noch vollständig abkühlen
dann wird sie auch ein wenig fest da von
der konsistenz und deshalb habe ich
diesen schritt auch schon einen tag
vorher zubereitet
genauso wie meine tortenböden hierfür
habe ich das rezept für meinen
schokoladen boden genommen jeweils zwei
mal gebacken und zwar in einer 22 cm
springform zum trinken nehme ich gerne
zuckersirup ich schreibe euch das wie
immer unten in die infobox und außerdem
benötigen wir unsere kalt gewordene
garage zu festes könnt ihr sie immer
wieder gerne über das wasserbad geben
damit ihr einem hotel artige konsistenz
bekommt zum füllen benötigen wir etwas
marmelade ich habe hier meine lieblings
waldfrucht marmelade genommen und ein
wenig tiefkühl hin werden
[Musik]
desweiteren benötigen wir eine batman
vorlage die hier habe ich online
gefunden ich verlinke ihr euch gerne in
die infobox und hier schneidet ihr euch
nur den kopf einmal aus
nun werden zuallererst unsere
schokoladen zurechtgeschnitten hierfür
schneide ich oben den ja minimalen hubl
ab damit wir das alles auch richtig
schön glatt haben und schneidet den
boden dann jeweils einmal durch
[Musik]
das gleiche machen wir dann auch mit dem
zweiten schokoladen boden und dann geht
es auch schon direkt weiter
[Musik]
damit die proportionen auch stimmt
nehmen wir uns jetzt insgesamt drei der
böden wir haben insgesamt vier
rausbekommen nachdem wie sie
durchgeschnitten haben und einen
tortenboden dem ich mir jetzt noch an
die seite der wird später aber definitiv
noch benötigt jetzt nehmen uns unsere
batman schablone und schneiden einmal
den kopf regens herum aus
[Musik]
die schablone habe ich bewusst ein wenig
größer ausgedruckt als der kuchen selbst
denn wir haben noch so viel rest zeigt
dass wir den kuchen optisch auch noch
verlängern können
aus den resten des schoko bodens
verlängere ich also den kopf damit dass
alles schön proportional aussieht und
füge auch schon mal die ohren mit hinzu
[Musik]
nun werden die böden nacheinander
getränkt und befüllt ich trinke ihnen
hier wie gesagt immer ganz gerne mit
meinem zuckersirup der ist vollständig
ausgekühlt und macht den kuchen noch ein
wenig saftiger
als nächstes gebe ich die marmelade
darauf die marmelade ist ein wenig
säuerlich auch nicht ganz so süß schaut
einfach welch marmelade euch da am
besten gefällt und sobald ihr das darauf
gegeben und verteilt habt gebt ihr ein
wenig danach darüber
[Musik]
nachdem eine dünne schicht ganache
darauf verteilt wurde geben wir den
nächsten boden mit hinzu und tränken
diesen auch wieder
[Musik]
diesmal möchte ich ein wenig abwechslung
mit reingeben und gebe deshalb
zuallererst die ganz auf den boden und
verteile darüber damit tiefkühl
himbeeren
[Musik]
die himbeeren habe ich mir auf meinem
schneidebrett zuvor etwas kleiner
geschnitten verteile sie dann aufdecker
marsch und anschließend geben wir noch
mal etwas cash darüber
[Musik]
nachdem das dann schön glatt gestrichen
wurde kommt der letzte boden oben drauf
und wird auch nochmal mit dem zucker
sirup gedrängt
[Musik]
was ihr hier seht ist der stehen
beziehungsweise oberkopf bereich von
batman und hier geben wir noch unsere
restlichen kuchenstücke mit hinzu und
kleben sie quasi mit der garage an
[Musik]
sobald ihr euch dann hoch gearbeitet
habt und fast oben angekommen seid
solltet ihr merken dass da noch ein
stück fehlt und jetzt kommt nämlich
unser letzter schoko wurde zum einsatz
den benötigen wir später auch noch mal
also nehmt euch zurück und nacht nicht
zu viel
jetzt stelle ich mir hier noch das
passende stück ab und klebe es ebenfalls
an den kopf
[Musik]
sobald das erledigt ist machen wir
weiter mit den ohren und die kleben wir
auch noch mit hilfe der garage an die
torte für den optimalen 3d effekte
werden die ohren jetzt nicht bis ganz
nach oben hin gestapelt sondern eher
eine ebene darunter
jetzt wird die torte komplett mit der
garage bestrichen allerdings reicht ist
hier wenn sie denn mit der kanal
streicht denn die erste schicht die nur
zur krümmel bindung ihr seht auch dass
meine garage etwas flüssiger ist ich
habe sie mir in die mikrowelle gegeben
weil ich finde dass man so besser
arbeiten kann in der ersten schicht für
die zweite schicht mag ich dann auch
gerne ein bisschen fester
nun müssen wir aber auch noch die
restlichen bestandteile des
gesichtsformen ich habe mir hier noch
passende stücke für die augenbrauen und
für die nase rausgesucht und solange die
garage noch nicht fest geworden ist
geben wir die auch noch darüber
die einzelnen stücke werden jetzt auch
noch mal mit der garage festgeklebt und
ich gibt so noch sieht der batman echt
lustig aus aber der wird später noch
richtig richtig cool werden
sobald ihr dann mit augenbrauen und nase
einigermaßen zufrieden seid denn später
werden wir das ganze auch noch mal in
form bringen geben wir die batman torte
vorerst für 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank so lange bis die ghanaer
schön fest ist
nun geht es ein wenig an die feinarbeit
ich starte zuallererst mit der
mundpartie die stelle habe ich mir hier
ausgeschnitten damit dies einfach ab und
gebe sie jetzt auf die torte
mit einem messer werden jetzt die
stellen auseinander kontur markiert
damit wir nachher auch genau wissen wo
wir schneiden müssen
[Musik]
außerdem markiere ich mir anhand der
schablone auch die lippen dass es immer
ganz praktisch dann wisst ihr ganz genau
wo sie anfängt und wo sie auf zu hören
hat und habe es später leichter mit dem
modellieren
nun schneide ich mir den kuchen etwa 1
cm in die tiefe ein und nehme den rest
raus das ist natürlich für die optik
ganz wichtig denn der batman trägt ihr
auch eine maske und sein gesicht ist
unter der maske weshalb für unbedingt
diesen party rausschneiden müssen
wichtig ist allerdings dass ihr die
lippen nicht aus schneidet denn die
ragende ein wenig hervor und deshalb
lassen wir die lippen auch so wie sie
sind an der stelle kümmern wir uns auch
schon direkt um die augen hierfür nehmen
wir einen teelöffel und höhlen da die
augen direkt unter den augenbrauen aus
wie kann es auch anders sein
und dann gibt's gleich auch schon weiter
um das markante gesicht von batman nach
kreieren zu können geht es jetzt um die
feinheiten hier schneide ich jetzt noch
am rand entlang etwas von den seiten ab
damit es auch so den anschein hat dass
er schlank ist und ein paar
wangenknochen hat und jetzt schneiden
wir unten damit es auch nicht so ganz
steil nach unten geht noch mal vom rand
etwas der torte ab damit wir auch eine
kleine rundung am boden haben
hier am kind an dieser partie könnt ihr
noch sehen dass ich unten ein ganz
großes stück abgeschnitten habe denn die
maske sitzt ja doch ziemlich eng an und
ich wollte dass das kind einfach hervor
steht
so jetzt geben wir noch mal etwas gerne
über die erste schicht diente ja zur
krümmel bindung und die zweite die
machen wir dann etwas großzügiger und
mit der zweiten schicht ghanas form wir
batman auch noch zu ende
mit hilfe der garage vor mich also noch
lippen und augenbrauen so wie sie mir am
allerbesten gefallen
hier nehmen die euch am besten
verschiedene winkel paletten zu hilfe
und ihr seht das endergebnis kommt dem
doch schon sehr nahe
sobald die garage auch schon
angetrocknet ist nehmt ihr euch am
allerbesten eure finger zu hilfe denn
damit könnt ihr die ganze auch noch mal
superform
jetzt muss das ganze komplett durch
gekühlt werden so ungefähr 30 minuten
lang damit das alles auch schön fest ist
meinen weißen fondant habe ich mir
bereits mit etwas brauner roter und
gelber lebensmittelfarbe hautfarben
eingefärbt jetzt wird der fondant auf
etwas becker stärker ausgerollt etwa ein
heim zentimeter dick und dann geht es
auch schon weiter
bevor ich den fondant jetzt allerdings
auf die torte lege besprüht sie komplett
mit etwas bakterien spray das ist
einfach neutrales öl aus der dose
das kann man gleichmäßig sprühen damit
es auch nicht zu trocken wird und er
fondant später richtig schön anklebt
die mund und kinnpartie drücke ich jetzt
schon fest an alles andere allerdings
noch nicht und hier könnt ihr euch auch
schon euer werkzeug zur hilfe nehmen um
das ganze auch gleichmäßig zu formen
den überschüssigen fondant schneide ich
jetzt schon mit einem marzipan messe ab
an der mundpartie gehe ich aber ganz
gerne mit einem scharfen messer entlang
dann habt ihr ein besseres gefühl dafür
und das ganze sieht auch ordentlicher
aus
[Musik]
jetzt wird alles schön mit den fingern
an gedrückt und anschließend könnt ihr
euch auch gerne nochmal eine winkel
palette nehmen um den mund wenn wir
nicht nachzuzeichnen
[Musik]
mit hilfe von ganz einfachen fondant
werkzeug könnt ihr dann noch die
nasenlöcher nach kreieren und hier gehe
ich ganz einfach diesen pool in die
löcher das hält er von land aus der
reißt auch nicht dann macht euch mal gar
keine sorgen und damit das ganze noch
ein wenig echter wird schiebe ich sie
auch noch ein wenig zur seite damit sie
nicht ganz so rund sind
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann noch das markante kinn
ein wenig nach gefahren beziehungsweise
nachgezeichnet habt geht es auch schon
weiter mit der restlichen maske da es
erfahrungsgemäß schwer ist eine große
menge weisen fondant schwarz zu färben
kauft ihr euch am besten schon vor
gefärbten schwarzen fondant anschließend
kniete die ihnen geschmeidig und rollt
ihn erneut auf etwas becker stärker aus
[Musik]
nun geben wir den schwarzen von land
großzügig komplett über den batman kopf
mit den fingern könnt ihr dann am besten
nach fühlen wo der schwarze von land
hingehört an den augenpartien
augenbrauen an der nase könnt ihr euch
dann richtig schön entlang arbeiten und
schneidet anschließend dem überschuss ab
[Musik]
jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch die
mundpartie aussparen hierfür nimmt ihr
euch am besten wieder scharfes messer
und schneidet ganz vorsichtig am und
entlang
[Musik]
bei den augen ist das ganze dann schon
etwas einfacher denn das sind ja ganz
einfach nur höhen da müsst ihr mit dem
messer einmal einschneiden den
überschuss herausnehmen und den rest an
den seiten ganz einfach eindrücken
[Musik]
da unser batman jetzt noch nicht böse
genug aussieht zeichnen wir die falten
nach schaut einfach auf die schablone
und dann könnte sie ganz nach belieben
einzeichnen
[Musik]
das funktioniert am besten wenn der von
land gerade frisch auf die torte gelegt
wurde dann kann man da noch richtig
schön einzeichnen und anschließend
nehmen wir auch den restlichen
überschüssigen fondant ab
[Musik]
für die pupillen nehmen wir uns jetzt
ganz einfach weißen fondant und geben
sie in die löcher hinein denn batman
sieht man auch nicht immer die pupillen
deshalb geben wir den weißen von land
hinein formen ein wenig mit unseren
händen und dann sind die augen auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
als nächstes bevor ich die torte zu ende
stelle bereite ich mich schon mal mein
cache bord vor
und dafür nehme ich mir ein 30 mal 40 cm
große skateboard streiche das mit etwas
kokosfett ein und gebe darüber mein gelb
eingefärbten und bereits dünn
ausgeräumten fondant drüber
[Musik]
jetzt gehe ich noch mal mit meinem
torten letter darüber damit das auch
richtig schön im cache bot haften kann
und schneide mit einem marzipan messer
den überschuss ab
[Musik]
da die torte super stabil ist können wir
sie jetzt ganz locker easy anheben und
auch unser tag bot geben
für den fast finalen schritt habe ich
mich etwas zucker kleber hergestellt ich
schreibe euch selbstverständlich noch
mal auf wie das funktioniert schotten
unten in der infobox und nehme ich mir
einen pinsel und streiche die maske ein
damit sie auch richtig schön glänzt
[Musik]
damit die lippen auch noch etwas mehr
tiefe bekommt geben wir auf und unter
den lippen noch etwas braunen
lebensmittel puder farbe
damit das skateboard jetzt nicht so
nackig aussieht und wir da auch noch ein
bisschen deko haben schneide ich mir
hier mit hilfe von batman ausstechen ein
paar batman fledermäuse aus und gebe sie
mit hilfe von zucker kleber darüber
[Musik]
damit die auch schön glänzen gebe ich
natürlich ebenfalls etwas zucker kleber
mit hilfe des pinsels darüber und dann
ist die batman torte auch schon fertig
so jetzt gespannt die tolle vorsieht
da hilft euch kopieren oder ist halt
schon verschmerzen spaß macht volker van
gaal ist sondern spaß mich gut und ich
[Musik]
hatte dich wir sehen uns dann hallo
doch ist vergessen hier
[Musik]